alors le nom prénom lundi matin 8 200
jeunes de tous les calibres s'apprête à
sauter sur les terrains des écoles de
soccer de l'impact qui offrent leur camp
de jour annuelle pour la semaine de
relâche et mais quand jean dynamique
avec nous qui nous apprennent plein de
choses et puis on est toujours content
sonner chez les alouettes qui ont
récemment acheté l'école de football
bruno et l on a soigneusement
sélectionnés 130 joueurs de 14 à 17 ans
pour un camp d'entraînement d'élite
violent d'emprunt de plus à l'ouest et à
l'est d'inde ou l'ipad des joueurs des
alouettes qui viennent parler aux jeunes
à chaque jour c'est un crochet des
alouettes qui est l'un des pôles d'une
adresse à 120 enfants du premier à
s'inscrire ont obtenu leur place pour le
cadre l'âge des canadiens beaucoup sont
nos fans viennent de partout en province
on a des gens disent et il va être dans
trois rivières
malheureusement on doit refuser des
inscriptions les parents n'hésitent pas
à investir 315 $ pour une semaine avec
l'impact
415 pour le camp du canadien et 700
dollars avec les alouettes qui offre
aussi l'hébergement complet pendant la
semaine
dans les trois cas les profits sont
minimes si ces familles ont choisi les
camps chapeauté par les équipes
professionnelles c'est notamment pour la
qualité des activités offertes
ça leur permet de développer leurs
habiletés techniques ça leur permet
aussi de développer le travail des
équipes
[ __ ] qui retournent dans leurs clubs
et ce à l'heure
donna un plus finalement est alors
beaucoup pour leur argent beaucoup de
conseils beaucoup de technique puis une
belle communauté
mais c'est aussi pour permettre à leurs
enfants de rêver un peu de goûter à une
expérience qui se rapproche du quotidien
des professionnels yard a donné de voir
l'agent de bijoux à la regarder leurs
ruches qui pratique à mike pratique
trouver les trucs à pacioretty
pas de doute les jeunes apprécient s'il
a parfois joué ici pichou vraiment
chouette
j'ai eu du temps pour assis à la place
de mon joueur préféré py qui se bat pour
les équipes
ça fait partie de leur engagement
communautaire mais ces camps sont aussi
une occasion de fidéliser leur jeune
clientèle
le forfait comprend d'ailleurs un
éventail d'articles promotionnels
les inscrits au camp de l'impact et des
alouettes reçoivent même des billets
pour un match c'est certain que les
jeunes s'attache à l'équipe c'est un but
c'est la relève
donc on veut que ces jeunes ne
s'intéressent bien au match profite de
l'expérience rencontre les joueurs on
sait que la plupart des gens qui
viennent une qui ont des billets sur
descamps reviennent une à deux fois au
stade dans la saison une semaine devrait
large qui profite donc aux parents comme
aux enfants et aux trois équipes
professionnelles montréalaise
et si jacinthe hayon radio canada
montréal